bonjour estelle alors la liste de pire
qu'ils suspendent leur trafic avec les
britanniques ne cesse de s'allonger
exactement olivier les britanniques
deviennent petit à petit persona non
grata on va d'abord regarder ce qu'il se
passe sur le continent européen
en tout ce sont 22 pays qui ont au moins
suspendu leurs liaisons aériennes avec
le royaume-uni la france par exemple
depuis dimanche minuit n'accueille plus
de personnes en provenance du sol
britannique
et cela concerne même les transports de
marchandises les frontières qu'elles
soient maritimes terrestres ou aériennes
sont fermés une décision prise pour 48
heures pour le moment contrairement à
l'allemagne le pays lui a carrément
suspendu toutes les liaisons aériennes
jusqu'au 31 décembre
même son de cloche en italie où l'entrée
du pays est interdite aux individus
ayant séjourné en grande bretagne ses 14
derniers jours l'italie qui a détecté
son premier cas de contamination à cette
nouvelle variante du coronavirus il
s'agit d'un patient rentrée du royaume
uni depuis un peu de temps une situation
qu observe aussi le danemark 1 puisque
neuf cas de cette nouvelle variante ont
aussi été à découvert sur le sol danois
alors évidemment là aussi un les vols
avec le royaume uni sont suspendus comme
partout en scandinavie d'ailleurs les
danois qui se retrouvent aussi privés de
déplacement à chez leurs voisins puisque
la suède a fermé sa frontière terrestre
avec le danemark depuis hier et du côté
du reste du monde on en est où estelle
et bien olivier un là aussi à les portes
se ferment petit à petit près d'une
vingtaine de pays ont suspendu leurs
vols ou ont interdit à l'entrée sur leur
territoire à quiconque ayant séjourné en
grande bretagne au cours des dernières
semaines alors vous allez le voir sur
cette carte qui s'affichent les
restrictions concernent de nombreuses
parties du globe de l'amérique latine
avec l'argentine ou le chili
la vie avec hong kong et l'inde en
passant par le moyen-orient avec
l'arabie saoudite ou encore le koweït
un dernier mot peut-être reste elle sur
l'union européenne qui tente de
coordonner sa stratégie face à cette
souche britannique
et oui olivier une première réunion
d'urgence a eu lieu hier matin à
bruxelles elle a permis à tout
simplement d'identifier à les options
possibles pour ouvrira les frontières de
manière coordonnée avec des mesures
identiques à chaque pays membre
alors après l identification et hier
place à l'harmonisation aujourd'hui
puisque ces options vont être soumises
aux ambassadeurs des pays membres
l'objectif selon une source diplomatique
et de taux et d'autoriser les
ressortissants de l'union européenne qui
se trouve au royaume uni les
britanniques qui résident dans l'union
et les chauffeurs de camions bloqués à
rentrer tout simplement au sein de
l'union à condition de présenter un test
pcr est négatif et puis toujours selon
cette source diplomatique les
britanniques ne seront ne devraient pas
être autorisés à rentrer sur le sol
européen apprend avant le 1er janvier
c'est en tout cas les recommandations de
la commission je vous le disais elles
vont être soumises aux pays membres
aujourd'hui par le biais des
ambassadeurs les pays qui travaillent
aussi à des solutions au-delà du 31
décembre
et puis pendant ce temps le comité de
sécurité sanitaire de l'union européenne
évalue cette dernière variante du
coronavirus prudence et coordination
donc semblent être les maîtres mots de
cette nouvelle gestion de crise merci
stèle pour toutes ces précisions le bric
site